j'ai noté que plusieurs formations
politiques étaient prêtes à faire
beaucoup plus j'ai été heureux de voir
ton enthousiasme je n'ai pas voulu leur
effréné mais j'ai déjà souhaité que ce
qui est le coeur de l'accord de tous
soient faits car c'est bien souvent ce
qui a été reculée reporter et tout fait
depuis des décennies le rôle de la
france est d'aller dans ce contexte
cherté chercher les soutiens
internationaux
c'est ce sur quoi je m'engage devant
vous ce soir c'est l'ensemble des
responsabilités et des décisions
auxquelles les forces politiques et les
responsables institutionnels et
politiques libanais se sont engagés
auprès de moi aujourd'hui et ce faisant
entrer deux joues sont au rendez en fin
je ne voudrais pas finir ce propos sans
évidemment évoqué aujourd'hui cette date
si chargé d'histoire ce 1er septembre
2020 qui vient marquer ce centenaire ici
même quelques heures après cette
déclaration si importante et cet acte
qui a donné naissance au bon niveau je
l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises avant mon
déplacement pendant ce déplacement
même avant cette date il y avait une
amitié une force une fraternité entre le
liban et la france qui s'impose à nous
et se poursuit et les se poursuit pour
ce que vous êtes pour ce que nous sommes
de commun l'indicible debout la
fraternité d'amour de la liberté des
exigences d'égalité
notre une 26 bien au peuple
il est notre devise
bien réussi parce que tous les principes
qui prévalent de tolérance d'art de
vivre sont ceux que nous portons et
c'est ce que j'ai retrouvé hier soir
dans les yeux de fée rousse dans la
discussion que nous avons pu avoir ce
matin auprès des enfants et des
volontaires dans la réserve d'usagé
auprès de ses enfants du collège
saint-joseph nommé chef qui ont chanté
know him d'un après l'autre
eric détermination de détermination chez
ces enfants
mais parfois la même colère que chez les
adultes mais la conviction qu'il n'avait
aucune raison de s'habituer au mal et
dans la dignité de la petite amara ce
matin il y avait beaucoup de là
d'essence et de la force de cette jolie
elle a en fait beaucoup à apprendre
pas beaucoup de monde et c'est pour
elles que nous devons nous battre et
donc ce centenaire je ne vois pas
simplement comme un moment de commémorer
mais comme la nécessité pour cette
jeunesse est ce qu elle me montre de
nous rappeler si guéret dans le discours
du grand liban dans le discours de gros
rouge d'évoquer ce midi avec le
président aoun et des mots très forts
je vais pas tout citer jour à sion il
brownies et n'oubliez pas non plus que
vous devez être prêt pour votre nouvelle
patrie à de réels sacrifices une patrie
nous secret que par l'effacement de
l'individualisme devant l'intérêt
général commandé par la fois dans les
destinées nationale de tous côtés les
témoignages affluent pour me manifester
cet esprit de sacrifice n'est ce pas
plusieurs des vôtres qui m'ont dit nous
sommes prêts désormais à faire bon
marché de notre bu neige car ces
privilèges était une garantie on ne
prend pas une garantie devant nos amis
on l'apprend devant des ennemis
voici grand libanais le sacré
d'espérance et de sacrifices que vous
apporte cet instant solennel
c'était il ya cent ans ça pourrait être
aujourd'hui
quelque chose s'est passé qui fait sans
doute que on n'a pas tant fait bon
marché des privilèges et que peut-être
que sur le dos de cette jeunesse
on les a fait fructifier il ne
m'appartient pas de me substituer un
grand peuple
mais en tout cas ma partie en même temps
après de voir que nous sommes pas
totalement au rendez vous de cette
exigence est donc ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous puissions être au
rendez-vous de cette exigence pour des
années qui viennent les mois qui
viennent parce que l'exigence commence
maintenant et je ne lâchais pas répondre
à vos questions
alors je crois qu'il ya un micro qui
passent encore tout chaud que ce que
vous avez fait la dernière fois qui est
d'avoir un micro fils parce que là
n'avait plus jamais revu mon sens le
seul président monsanto est sympa niveau
avant tout merci d'être venus comme vous
l'aviez promis
ma question est la suivante si dans les
prochaines semaines les rendez-vous sont
ok si les promesses de réforme ne sont
pas tenues concrètement que l'eau et
vous c'est à dire est ce que comme vous
l'avez laissé entendre lors de la
prochaine conférence vous serez prêts à
activer une politique de sanctions
individuelles contre les principaux
dirigeants libanais four nations
merci pour cette question elle est
importante et je vous remercie de parler
des sanctions j'en avais parlé de la
dernière fois ce qui n'a pas empêché
certains d'entre vous décrire les pires
bêtises sur le sujet sans vérification
non plus donc j'invite quand vous avez
des questions sur le sujet allait poser
directement
ça facilitera les choses parce que ce
sont des sujets graves
écoutez j'ai coutume de citer levinas
disait la confiance c'est le problème de
l'eau
moi je fais confiance
mais je le dis très clairement si
rendez-vous de fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons intégrer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien été et ce moment là c'est
clair je devrais dire à la communauté
internationale
nous ne pouvons pas être rendez-vous de
l'aide au liban mais je dois aussi vous
expliquer et expliquer aux libanaises de
lui l'année nous étions prêts à vous
aider nos dirigeants ont décidé
autrement
il n'y a pas 50
c'est la première étape et avant
d'enclencher des réalismes de sanctions
on n'emploie pas les mécanismes de
sanction parce que des gens ne prennent
pas leurs responsabilités politiques
parce que ça c'est autre chose on
devient sinon la rive d'un jeu politique
c'est déjà de dire nous passons un
contrat il y a ce sur quoi vos forces
politiques vos responsables se sont
engagés là qu'ils doivent mener à bien
et en face de ça
l'aide de la communauté internationale
c'est ce premier contrat qui si le
rendez vous n'est pas là et s'ils
travaillaient pas fait ce délire est
donc la première chose que je ferai
c'est que j'essaie de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé en transparence d'attributs
les responsabilités politiques et je
vous le dirai en toute franchise et très
concrètement ça veut dire qu'une partie
des mécanismes qu'il devait accompagner
le peuple libanais les politiques
publiques ne pourra pas pratiquer la
deuxième question vous posez ensuite
c'est si des responsabilités plus larges
que ça de corruption
de participation à des activités non
légales sont identifiés pour des
responsables qui permettent à ce
moment-là d'activer des mécanismes de
sanction c'est quelque chose que
certains grands pays font je n'ai pas de
discussion avec eux sur sept -
contrairement encore une fois ce qui a
pu être dit ou écrit parce que d'abord
ça n'est pas la dynamique dans laquelle
je suis engagée aujourd'hui est que la
france est un pays souverain qui fait
pour lui même et qui le cpi le faire
pour eux mêmes nous avons généralement
une coordination européenne en la
matière je pense que ce moment peut
venir
je les dis la dernière fois je le répète
je ne l'exclus aucunement il doit venir
au bon moment s'ils s'imposent et de
manière ciblée politique de sanctions se
fait quand on définit les
responsabilités qui à ce moment là
peuvent devenir extraconstitutionnelle
ils ne s'inscrivent pas simplement d'un
championnat et après vous savez très
bien les mécanismes de sanctions peuvent
s'activer aussi quand on a des activités
extra légales qui peuvent être de type
militaire ou terroriste de type
financière autres et en fonction des
évolutions je n'exclus pas un mécanisme
de sanctions en effet plus large qui
peut dans certains cas être activée
c'est pas du tout la configuration dans
laquelle elle le libre aujourd'hui mais
c'est une configuration qu'on a connu
nous conduit aujourd'hui pour d'autres
crises régionales mais ça n'est à coup
sûr par des tables d'hôtes or parce que
nous sommes dans un processus
mais ce processus est d'abord un
processus de confiance d'engagements
réciproques
daisy jans si on veut faire vivre la
confiance alors que je vois à chaque
seconde la défiance par tour
ici il faut s'engager il faut demander
aux gens de s'engager il faut fixer des
rendez-vous et attendre le rendez vous
avant de dire c'est impossible c'est cet
esprit
un jour j'ai pas de microbes en soirée
le président julien lécuyer de la voix
du nord vous avez rencontré à deux
reprises le premier ministre moustapha
dieng beaucoup ici s'interroge sur sa
marge de manoeuvre vert pour engager les
réformes en profondeur
quelles garanties at il pu vous donner
sur la méthode est question calendrier
nous avait répondu alors largement mais
yat-il houcine talent putois pour des
élections législatives anticipées
merci sur le deuxième sujet il n'y a
aujourd'hui pas l'objet d'un consensus
entre les forces politiques
soyons très clairs et c'est un sujet qui
dépend évidemment de ceux qui ont cette
décision constitutionnellement en un mot
liban et de la réalité politique et de
la société civile et donc sur ce sujet
n'est pas un esprit mais ça fait pas
partie de l'agenda de réformes qui
couvre les trois prochains mois nous
allons les débats
j'ai vu des désaccords et jeu j'ai
simplement essayé de convaincre
l'ensemble des parties de dire que le
sujet sur la loi électorale ne doit pas
être un préalable à la mise en oeuvre
des réformes parce que sinon on peut
mettre les réformes en place dans
plusieurs années c'est possible ça a
déjà été fait donc ce sujet ne fait pas
partie de ce qui aujourd'hui fait
l'objet d'un consensus entre d'un
engagement de toutes les forces
politiques libanaises comme des
présidents j'ai vu pour la première fois
et puis échangé pour la première fois
hier soir avec le premier ministre
désigné est gelé leur phrasé ce midi
rapidement écoutez qu'est ce que je peux
vous dire
la première chose il a sur le plan
politique un soutien massif des forces
politiques même s'il n'est pas unanime
en tous cas de manière explicite
plus largement que précédemment les
forces politiques libanaises présente au
parlement se sont engagés derrière son
premier le deuxième il a un parcours qui
est un gage de professionnalisme et de
probité au troisième il est lucide il
s'est rendu hier dans les rues et nous
en avons parlé très librement
il sait qu'il n'est pas si je puis
utiliser ce terme sans créer de
polémique inutile
attendu comme le messie
clairement il n'est pas vu comme le
sauveur et il le sait pas pour ce qu'il
est parce qu'il est le fruit de la
désignation de forces politiques qui
n'ont plus la confiance du peuple je les
dis très clairement aux intéressés
qu'ils le savent mais c'était tout le
débat qu'on attend ensemble le 6 août
dernier nous en sommes là et les forces
politiques sont là qu'ils ont été élus
démocratiquement dans le cas d'une loi
électorale qui est la vôtre par un père
qui le veau et on ne peut pas rompre
avec cette légitimité en un jour seul le
peuple libanais pas un dirigeant
étranger où il m'appartient pas moins de
deux qualifiés ou lui donner un autre
statut
mais il est très lucide sur sept étages
cet état de fait est longue
je crois pouvoir dire que sa conviction
est que cette légitimité ne peut
l'acquérir d'abord conformant rapidement
un gouvernement
et je crois que cette légitimité d'une
forte ce soir qu'hier car l'accord de
toutes les forces qui le soutiennent
dirigeant a été explicite ce soir
gouvernement de mission fait de
professionnels avec l'idée qu' on ne va
pas partir pour des mois de traque 7 de
tractations chacun n'en aura quelqu'un
qui le représente
mais où on va laisser le premier
ministre proposait une équipe la plus
solide possible et qu'il y aura ensuite
un débat avec les forces politiques et
autres éléments
c'est la déclaration gouvernementale sa
feuille de route pour les prochains mois
est celle que les forces politiques
le cil président président de
l'assemblée ont en quelque sorte
sécrétée par leur discussion commune et
le travail des dernières semaines
15h et les quelques raisons que j'ai
évoquées là avec un calendrier je crois
que ça lui donne une assise d'une
capacité à réussir parce que le mandat
est clair et explicite il est impératif
je dirais quasiment tous ces éléments
sont des éléments inédits dans votre vie
politique contemporaine
en tout cas très différents des réalités
précédentes et c'est ce qui fait que je
le crois très profondément
si chacun tient sa parole et
l'engagement explicite qu'il a pris les
uns avec les autres et vis-à-vis de
moi-même je crois pouvoir dire qu'il
pourra faire les réformes auxquelles ils
s'engagent
monsieur le président mon soir ces gens
et vous invite à un mois après le drame
atroce de mes routes lankais talence pas
la classe politique criminelle s'est
montré insensible à la souffrance du
peuple sinistré et à la nuit du pays et
en même temps même après l'explosion les
manifestants ont été réprimés violemment
par usage d'armes à feu
quelques heures avant de vous accueillir
à l'aéroport de beyrouth le président
libanais et challenges a interdit à
utiliser la chaîne que je me présente
d'avoir accès au palais présidentiel
pour couvrir les concertations
parlementaire uniquement à cause de
notre ligne éditoriale
en tant que président de la ligue
française qui est le berceau des
libertés et des trois hommes pensiez
vous est ce qu'on peut penser qu'on
pourrait vraiment aspirer à la pire
manière meilleur temps que ces pratiques
est inamissible continue vous avez aussi
dit que le football est un parti qui est
élu par le peuple
pensez vous que les les élections
législatives avoir lieu en toute liberté
tant qu'il ya un groupe armé qui est en
train d'intimider ses opposants
par la force des armes et par sa
mainmise sur l'état et s'ils ont le
pouvoir
pensez vous qu'on pourrait vraiment
avoir entre qu'on pourrait vraiment
entamer un dialogue pour la route
du système dans de telles conditions
monsieur le président et est ce que vous
auriez eu les mêmes propos par rapport
2ème aulas il s'agissait d'un groupe
armé en france merci alors sur deux
questions sur la première je veux dire
un mot de l'enquète nous coopérons d'un
point de vue technique à la demande des
enquêteurs libanais je peux vous dire
que les coopérations techniques se passe
bien qu'elle permette d'avancer et
d'établir les faits et donc maintenant c
est un débat qu'il y aura dans les
prochaines semaines et qui est important
pour le peuple libanais pour les
victimes leurs familles c'est que la
transparence soit faite pleine et
entière à l'égard de celle-ci et de
votre peuple et qu ensuite les
responsabilités s'il y en a qui sont
identifiés soit assigné ce soit suivi
d'effets ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'elle enquête avance et que nous
coopérons techniquement ça c'est
important
pour finir vous rassurer et aussi dire
que plusieurs autres pays est en paix
internationaux coopèrent à la demande ni
mains libres qui fournir des images
satellites des données qui soulève
deuxième élément sur le contexte
politique
concerne votre chaîne et les derniers
jours je ne peux pas le commenter parce
que je ne le connais pas et donc je ne
veux pas me permettre de mini c'est dans
ce débat particulier et le fait que vos
cités dont je ne connais pas les faits
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que il
y à de la violence qu'il y a aujourd'hui
des artistes des intellectuels des
journalistes qui considèrent que leur
liberté d'expression
aujourd'hui ne peut pas s'exercer de
manière à raison c'est un débat que j'ai
eues avec les autorités et donc je pense
que le rôle de la france c'est d'avoir
cette exigence d d ensemble des
journalistes des artistes pas simplement
les protéger les arrêtés ont-ils veulent
fuir le pays ce qu'on fait aussi mais de
les aider à pratiquer ici c'est
d'ailleurs exactement le sens des
initiatives que nous allons porter
depuis maintenant un peu plus de deux
ans avec réseau reporters sans
frontières initiatives que nous avons
enclenchée aux formes de paris pour la
paix puis que nous avons porté à l'oeil
nu quand justement défendre exactement
sur ces principes sur tous les théâtres
d'opérations des journalistes
observateurs
je me permets d'y adjoindre simplement
les intellectuels et les artistes
ce que vous dites est très important et
je pense que la dignité du liban son
peuple c'est que cette liberté soit
respecter de manière scrupuleuse et donc
là aussi qu'on puisse améliorer les
choses sur ce volet c'est une discussion
que gym avec vos dirigeants et que nous
allons poursuivre mais l'exigence est là
en soutien avec les ong qui sont
compétentes sur ce sujet pour ce qui est
de la france en appui de l'onu qui dans
le cadre de ses missions peut aussi vous
protéger et dans le débat exigeant que
nous avons avec vos dirigeants et je
l'espère pour la suite des réformes
sur le sujet des élections législatives
ce que vous dites est un état de fait et
nous avons eu cette discussion de
manière très franche de thaler autour de
la table y compris avec le représentant
de l'osce paul est ce que vous décrivez
est juste et ce qu'il m'appartient à moi
pour autant d'invalider des élections de
dire je refuse de reconnaître une force
politique
je ne parle pas du hezbollah dans sa
composante militaire et terroriste sur
laquelle la france a toujours été clair
qu'elle condamne mais sur le volant
temps fort politique est-ce qu'il est
élu dans des conditions de sincérité du
scrutin a fait je ne suis pas le juge de
votre scrutin l'observation
internationale le bon sens ne conduisent
plutôt à penser que ce que vous dites
est vrai et juste et donc qu'il faut
améliorer les choses sont si je voulais
être dans la pureté des intentions
je condamnerai le hezbollah dans sa
plénitude
je dirais je refuse de parler au
hezbollah en tant que formation
politique à votre parlement en tant que
partenaires politiques de la majorité
que vous avez élu elle ce qui vous pose
par rapport aux autres questions
un autre principe politique et
constitutionnelle et je vous dirai c'est
très simple il faut les condamner les
désarmer et je repartirai chez moi il
vous resterait avec votre problème je
n'aurais
gérez votre problème et je pense
d'ailleurs que toutes les hypothèses et
les libanais qui vivent en france me
dirai merci président vous avez bien
parler mais je n'aurai aucune action
utile
j'essaie de dire ce que je pense la
vérité au plus près et d'avoir une
action est sans doute le hezbollah est
il une force politique présente à votre
parlement parce qu'il ya de
l'intimidation et parce qu'il joue sur
cette dualité ce que vous dites est vrai
il est aussi sans doute parce que
beaucoup d'autres forces politiques
n'ont pas réussi à bien diriger le pays
à rendre les gens plus heureux aussi
celles sans doute un peu vrai et que si
on continue comme ça il sera de plus en
plus fort parce qu'avec des moyens ne
sont pas celui des autres forces
politiques
des pratiques qui ne sont pas reconnus
par leur vie internationale
parfois une plus grande efficacité sur
le terrain
socialement culturellement il a une
clientèle
c'est ça la réalité je vous parle très
franchement moi j'essaie avec vous
d'avoir un discours sincère et de ne pas
m'en robes et dans l'es16 et donc par
rapport à votre question je vous ai
répondu très précisément de la manière
la plus sincère comment on en sort
paraît des mots dans une déclaration qui
n'est pas consensuelle et qui fait que
au fond le partenaire de votre parti
majoritaire vous ne traitez pas et donc
vous pouvez vous amuser à bloquer les
réformes mais en veillant discours
sincère avec le hezbollah formation
politique
en lisant vous voyez bien que c'est un
problème pour vous aussi aujourd'hui
c'est exactement la discussion que nous
avons des docks est notre prochain
rendez vous pour les prochaines réformes
on doit parler de ce sujet est ce qu'on
arrive à le résoudre tout de suite je ne
sais pas ça ne va pas être un tellement
mais est ce que c'est un principe qui
interdit toute discussion sur le reste
ça marche pas donc je suis comme je
voulais déjà vit un vrai idéaliste c'est
à dire un réel fallu matic
je crois au principe je n'ai défend je
sais mon horizon
je ne cède rien par rapport à ça mais
j'essaie de construire avec vous le
chemin le chemin pour arriver à
l'endroit on est alors c'est pas moi qui
donne le micro il faut que quelqu'un
demande
après toute façon je connais ça tournera
alesi nous c'est le président menadi a
des droits du liban
en fait le premier ministre a été
désigné suite à des concertations des
parties libanaises diverses qui sont sur
la scène et qui sont contestés par le
peuple
nous sommes un tout petit peu en train
d'évoluer dans un cercle vicieux est ce
que la france peut contribuer à défaire
ce noeud gordien moi je crois dans la
souveraineté des peuples et donc
le moment que vous vivez que nous vivons
janvier je me sens maintenant si prenant
la place une communauté
c'est la crise au sens gramscien du
terne
le neuf a du mal à émerger et lens est
toujours là tarder à partir
vous avez raison de dire qu'il ya des
mouvements dans la rue king est une
société civile qui est là et elle unie
at-elle un leader non force est de le
constater
la politique c'est aussi du leadership
et donc il n'y a pas un leader qui
s'impose c'est pas entendu j'entends des
gens ce qu on verrait lui
alors qu'est ce que ça peut donner la
souveraineté populaire par un moment
s'affirmer et et l'emporté sur un
système politique qui n'a plus de
résultats c'est un mois qu'il fallait
faire je n'ai pas à interférer sur ce
sujet la france et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'aucune puissance étrangère n'a
interpellé sur ce sujet c'est un sujet
du peuple libanais avec son histoire
il ya une deuxième façon de faire c'est
que cette ce mouvement social trouver un
débouché politique ces fameux sujet des
téléphones est ce qu'avec la même loi
littoral ce mouvement social couvrant un
débouché beaucoup on y compris beaucoup
de gens j'ai pu rencontrer quand sont
les acteurs c'est là où je sais que
toutes les circulaires et donnez nous
des élections pour qu'on s'exprime
oui mais avec quels droits humains
différentes mais qui fait cette loi
les gens qui sont autour de la table et
qui sont démocratiquement élu par la loi
existante dans le cadre de notre
constitution
si on joue la continuité démocratique
ça ne peut s'installer que parce que
l'ensemble en tout cas une majorité des
forces présentes pour a
constitutionnellement défini de
nouvelles règles du jeu qui permet
il est trop tôt pour eux mais je pense
que les possibilités sont là alors
comment andré ce noeud avec beaucoup
d'espoir et de volonté et ce que j'ai
ressenti ma conviction c'est que si
aujourd'hui on ne met pas la pression
pour des réformes de court terme qui
sont importants pour le quotidien des
libanaises et des libanais pour qu'on
puisse soigner vivre se nourrir mieux
vivre retrouver l'espoir éduquer
si on ne fait pas ça si on n'est pas une
pression sur le système pas pour sauver
le système est lui-même mais pour
redonner un peu d'espoir et d'énergie au
peuple libanais à ce moment là on joue
la politique du pire et je pense que
cette politique du pire est une faute
profonde
pour ce qui est de la france
parce que je pense que les plus solides
ce ne sont pas ceux qui manifestent dans
la rue ce ne sont pas de ceux qui la
roumanie vous êtes à un moment critique
de votre histoire où il faut ou bien que
le système politique se transforme de
lui-même et cette force pour
correspondre aux aspirations du peuple
ou bien que le peuple trouve le chemin
démocratique de sa propre représentation
est peut-être un peu des deux convergent
un système politique lucide sur lui-même
qui voit qu'il faut que la société
civile prennent plus de place et une
société civile qui est celle de l'entrée
dans le champ politique
ou bien peut-être c'est par des spasmes
politiques sociaux que le changement se
fera et donc peut-être par des voies
extraconstitutionnelle je vous décrivais
avec possible je pense que en tout cas
ce que nous avons à faire c'est de ne
jamais laisser la politique du pire
l'emporter la politique du pire c'est de
dire laissé libre à lui même
les gens se lasseront le désespoir
gagnera les gens intelligents qu'ils
peuvent quitteront le pays et
l'obscurantisme l'emportera je pense que
c'est ça
certains parisiens
en se disant à un moment il y aura une
crise et on se séparera des forces
politiques qu'on n'aime pas qu'on parle
et je pense que ça c'est
l'anéantissement du liban pour un temps
et quand un pays ces fonds ne s'est
jamais cancéreux et donc je le battrai
mais pour ses scénarios n'arrive pas je
me battais avec vous
mais ce président dont soir je suis leur
magasin je pose cette question pour les
échos vous avez fait des annonces très
ambitieuse au ce soir notamment sur les
engagements obtenus par vos
interlocuteurs
mais aujourd'hui libre il ya beaucoup de
gens je pense aux libanais qui mène la
contestation dans la rue
encore cet après midi comme ma consoeur
libanaise bhl a rappelé je pense à des
intellectuels à des représentants de la
société civile des politologues et
juristes qui pensent que le pouvoir
n'est pas au moment de gens qui sont aux
responsabilités aujourd'hui au liban
c'est à dire de gens qui ne sont pas
responsables devant les libanais ou
class 10 on a une liste de connu donc
aucun nom ne figure dans aucun
organigramme d'une institution
officielle commencé pour monsieur le
président vous repreneur d engagement
crédible de réformes de gouvernance
quand vos interlocuteurs ne sont pas
ceux qui tiennent les rênes du pays je
vous remercie
alors d'abord je me permettrai de
rectifier votre début de questions je
n'ai pas fait danos
ce qui serait la mienne je vous ai rendu
compte des engagements pris par
l'ensemble des forces politiques sur une
feuille de route qui adore
c'est un goût est important
je vous êtes plus experts que moi mais
j'ai quand même le sentiment que quand
on voit les présidents qui j'ai échangé
à mi journée et l'ensemble des
dirigeants des forces politiques
prennent pas forcément des ministres
d'hier d'attenté avec les forces
politiques
j'ai le sentiment qu'on voit les gens
qui tirent les ficelles que d'être avec
moi donc si ces gens là s'engage
normalement je suis en droit de leur
demander des comptes
donc je pense étaient les bonnes
personnes alors après beaucoup de femmes
et hommes qui sont dans la rue me
reprochent de les voir moi je ne les
connaissais pas avant je les ai
rencontrés pour la première fois le
sujet ce qui donne une fraîcheur nous
échanges mais
c'est exactement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure moi je connais que le système
que vous avez démocratiquement qui a été
démocratiquement élu en vertu de la
constitution et les lois électorales
c'est pas à moi de désigner des leaders
sinon je nuis à souveraineté du peuple
et vous savez les occidentaux par le
passé ont parfois essayé ce jeu compris
dans la région
ce n'est pas une bonne idée de dire je
suis plus intelligent que la
souveraineté populaire vos dirigeants ne
me laisse pas d'ailleurs il ya des gens
qui manifestent vous allez voir on va
régler les choses on va nous changer vos
dirigeants
sa fille ni moins bien donc on est dans
cette dialectique au fond c'est ça pour
briser la circularité dans laquelle le
niveau est enfermé il faut créer une
dialectique d'éthique c'est un parfait
ça peut prendre un peu plus de temps le
chemin n'est pas une gentille impossible
parce que si les acteurs en présence
avait l'énergie la force d'âme et tous
les intérêts liés pour le faire il
aurait pas besoin ont remplacé des
heures à faire deux pages de
l'engagement il aurait fait depuis 10
ans 20 ans 30 ans mais je pense que
quelque chose se passe dans le pays et
dans la rue dans la région dans la
gravité historique du moment que nous
vivons que nous partageons et peut-être
de leur vie ce qui fait que une
responsabilité particulière résonne suis
pas naïf en disant ça et je dis que
peut-être le kairos est là
et donc dans ces moments là il faut
s'engager mais ce sera forcément une
vérité c'est à dire qu'il y aura des
avancées elles sont imparfaites
d'hercule mais je pense que le chemin
est ce que ce chemin sera exclusivement
politique exclusivement de la société
civile un mariage des deux les
libanaises et les libanais devant moi je
veux simplement de toutes mes forces
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent le faire
librement et que ça ne soit pas édicté
par simplement quelques-uns qui sont
plus forts que peu ou par des puissances
extérieures
bonjour monsieur le président russe il y
enseigne aux confirmés vous vous serez
en irak demain et qu'elle fera l'objet
de cette visite
parlerez vous avec vos interlocuteurs de
ces djihadistes france et emprisonné sur
leur sort et quel est aujourd'hui votre
son je vous confirme que je serai demain
matin en irak et que avec le ministre
nous aurons l'occasion de lancer en lien
avec les nations unies
une initiative pour accompagner le
président le premier ministre et le
gouvernement irakien sur véritablement
justement une démarche de souveraineté
lui le sujet que vous évoquez est un
sujet qui est aujourd'hui bien structuré
connue qui fait l'objet d'échangés
techniques et ministérielles la position
de la france a toujours été la même non
nos ressortissants qui font le choix
libre d'aller combat sur des théâtres
extérieurs et qui se rendent coupables
d'actions terroristes sur le sol d'un
état souverain sont légitimement gillis
irisé sur le sol de cet état souverain
dans le cadre des coopérations
judiciaires qui sont les nôtres
simplement nous demandons comme
d'ailleurs le fond de partenaires
européens
dans les cas où la peine de mort elle
prononcée que celle ci puisse être
commuée conformément à notre droit à nos
principes dans des peines de prison à
perpétuité voilà le principe qui sont
les nôtres et qui régissent ce sujet
mais c'est le début d'une initiative
in profond que nous allons à ces deux
ans en irak après les beaucoup de
travail avec le président le premier
ministre dans un pays qui a beaucoup
souffert de la guerre du terrorisme
islamiste et de l'ingérence des
puissances extérieures et qui continuent
d'en souffrir
et donc là aussi des deux structures et
avec les nations unies la communauté
internationale
une dizaine profonde en soutien du
président lula pour ça la france joue
aujourd'hui un très grand rôle au liban
et son chemin de l'effort mais d'autres
forces régionaux internationale
notamment lire un livre en l état c'est
sonia sotomayor ou même les etats-unis
ont leur propre apport quelles sont les
garanties qu'ils ne vont pas tarder ce
programme d'avancement l'état libanais
gros votre avis au mois
il m'est arrivé de d'essayer de faire
des médiations en tout cas de travailler
avec certaines des puissances que vous
évoquez parfois même les deux ces
expériences me conduisent à la plus
grande humidité et donc je ne me plierai
pas pour autrui ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que en engageant cette démarche
j'ai pris le soin de parler à tous les
dirigeants internationaux qui sont dans
l'europe international de soutien à
d'autres et j'ai eu un échange avec le
président voit ni et le prince héritier
salman sur les initiatives qui était la
nôtre et la démarche conjointe et donc
qu'ils sont up sa démarche serait en
transparence avec eux et avec en tout
cas des mots qui me fait penser qu'ils
sont ceux d'une volonté de laisser le
libre emmené son chemin
je ne suis pas là aussi naïf
est ce que tous les liens qui existent
soient publiques ou qu'ils soient privés
ou sont privés se dénoueront du jour au
lendemain non mais je pense que le
programme sur lequel se sont engagés
s'engage le premier ministre pour force
politique des présidents est
suffisamment précis concrets et de court
terme pour que ces puissances qu'on
évoque n'est pas un intérêt à le mettre
en péril
je pense ensuite il y aura à coup sûr
des divergences s'agira de la brouille
du graal quand il s'agira de la
vérification du sujet des arbitres a
annoncé mais pas à ce stade
voilà donc un sur peu avancé
de qui
non je ne dirais pas un peu à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de sauveur de quiconque à
donner à qui que ce soit vous avez des
dirigeants responsables qui s'engagent
d'éléphant pour votre pays prennent
leurs responsabilités comme dirigeant le
forces politiques et responsables
c'est une tournée qui s'engagent et qui
donne le feu vert mais sur cette
démarche d'ensemble
je vous le dis il ya eu un échange très
lourde avec ces puissances et je ne vois
pas prendre une lettre de réformes
m'intéresse aussi de les mettre en péril
le président soit on meurt je suis
d'accord avec vous ce dont vous rêvez
n'existe pas
et ce dont vous rêvez je ne peux pas
vous la portez sur un plateau je
n'allais pas la possibilité
il ya une chose qu'on peut rebâtir étape
par étape c'est une forme de confiance
allaient relatif n'efface pas le passé
mais c'est d'essayer de dire comment on
a des résultats concrets sinon ne reste
que le désespoir ou les désabusés et moi
j'ai je me sens le devoir à l'égard de
toutes celles et ceux que je sans
désespérer ici ou à l'étranger face à la
situation
ce que j'aimerais ordonné un chemin pour
qu'ils agissent et qu'ils reprennent
qu'ils fassent tout ce qu'ils peuvent et
je pense que toutes les libanaises et
lee valley où qu'ils soient ont un rôle
dans cette période essentiel à jouer
dans parler avec quelques-uns guerre
qu'ils soient artistes entrepreneurs
intellectuels je pense que quelque chose
peut se réinventer maintenant mais je
pense qu'on n'a pas le droit pour
reprendre la formule de rimbaud de
rester assis oui même si c'est pas gagné
on va se battre c'est le président s'est
marié rallye fait j'ai une question sur
fait rose et à vous avez rencontré notre
diva fait vous pouvez vous nous raconter
quelques détails sur cette rencontre
exceptionnelle et une deuxième question
sur votre rencontre avec le patriarche
alors oui j'ai rencontré le patriarche
quelques minutes presque
rires pour heures cent ans après
l'implication d'un de ses prédécesseurs
en ce même lieu et donc nous avons comme
nous avons pu le faire lors de notre
précédente rencontre évoquer la
situation du pays il m'a fait part dé de
la position qui est la sienne et des
initiatives qu'il a pu rendre au public
ces derniers temps sur la neutralité
active et donc sur ce point un jeu nous
avons eu un échange politique je crois
qu'il ya une volonté de s'engager sur ce
sur ce sujet j'ai dit que là où elle est
de la france évidemment vous savez dans
l'esprit exactement ce que j'évoque
depuis tout à l'heure et que la france
étant engagée dans cette philosophie et
cet esprit et donc il soutiendra de deux
là où elle est comme elle le peut au
maximum de ce qu'elle peut et nous avons
également évoqué le sujet des écoles
seigneur gollnisch it est partie
prenante à ce rendez vous va doré ont
fait un très grand travail mais comme je
le disais nous avons pu évoquer aussi le
fond des personnages que nous avons
mises en place et toutes les initiatives
prises et que nous allons continuer sur
ce sujet vous m'autoriserai à rester
pudique quant à fait rose
moi je peux vous dire ce que j'ai
ressenti et une part des cibles de ce
que je lui dis moi j'étais très
intimidée d'abord de voir un immense
diva et devoirs sont sombres
sa beauté son humilité de magie qu'elle
a c'est très grande conscience politique
et je lui dis une chose que je crois
très profondément équivaut pour elle
comme beaucoup d'eux d'artistes ici ou à
l'étranger et de toutes générations et y
compris les des artistes qui aujourd'hui
prennent beaucoup de risques pour dire
la vérité du liban la dessiner l'écrire
ou la chanter où la mettre en film ou en
chorégraphie c'est que ces voix sont
importantes et que la voie de fait rose
comme d'autres voies et sous de ces
générations et tous césar ça n'est pas
l'accessoire
même dans ces temps de crise dans tous
les sens du terme
c'est presque le plus important c'est ce
qui redonne un motif d'espérer et je
pense qu'elle porte
de manière fantasmer aurait elle une
part d'un liban rêvait peut-être qu'il
n'a jamais existé
et pour toutes celles qui veulent
liban dont se disent c'est impossible
parce que ce serait faux et donc je
pense que sa voix est importante encore
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je lui dis
j'espère qu'elle aussi elle trouvera le
chemin et je pense qu'elle a elle a
quelque chose à faire moi je j'essaie de
pousser chacun à faire un petit peu puis
enfin je vous dirai pas plus et je ne
parlerai pas pour elle parce que je
trouve que la part de mystère dont elle
sait nabé fait partie aussi de cette
force la respecte non
nous avons parlé et parfois nous nous
sommes tus je les cite ayez basse que je
vais citer libéraux route et dernière
question toute dernière question après
il ya une toute la question s'est
terminée après je remercie ceux qui
n'ont pas été posées bonsoir ça monsieur
présidente julie marie lecomte france
info le liban c'est un art de vivre
ensemble vous l'avez encore répété en
france à la veille du procès des
attentats janvier 2015
la rédaction de charlie hebdo a décidé
de re publié les caricatures de mahomet
qu'en pensez vous ah je pense qu'un
président de la république en france n'a
jamais a qualifié le choix éditorial
d'un journaliste ou d'une rédaction
jamais parce qu'il ya une liberté de la
presse à laquelle vous tenez à juste
titre profondément et ensuite dans notre
pays depuis le début de la troisième
république dont vendredi d'ailleurs nous
célèbrerons les un anniversaire
important c'est d'abord à cet
anniversaire
ils sont cinquante ans de la république
il ya aussi en france une liberté de
blasphémer qui est attachée à la liberté
de conscience
et donc de là où je suis je suis là pour
protéger toutes ses libertés
donc je n'ai pas à qualifier le choix de
journalistes j'ai juste à dire en france
on peut critiquer des gouvernants un
président blasphémer etc
après en face de cela pour que le débat
démocratique tiennent et ça ne vaut pas
du tout pour eux les caricatures parce
que la caricature fait partie justement
de cette il y as parce que souvent ce
droit de critiquer ou best fait mais
encore une fois je ne parle pas du tout
changé de dôme et de largement ce qui
est ce qu'on peut voir dans notre
société
il implique en revers une décence
commune une civilité un respect parce
qu'il y a en france toutes ces libertés
la liberté de conscience la liberté
d'expression liberté des journalistes de
faire ses choix
liberté de blasphème il y a le devoir de
ne pas avoir deux discours de haine et
de respecter le discours de haine il se
justifie dans des pays où la liberté
n'existe pas ou l'alternance politique
n'existe pas nous sommes un pays où
toutes ces libertés sont défendus ou
constitutionnellement ou par les lois
fondamentales de notre république
garantit où on peut changer la vie
politique
à chaque échéance j'en suis la preuve
vivante
y compris quand on est hors du système
tout ça impose aux citoyens que nous
sommes
le respect est donc de ne jamais sombrer
dans les discours de haine
je le dis parce que c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui nous manque dans le
débat commun qui n'a rien à voir avec la
une de charlie parce que la caricature
n'est pas un discours de haine mais qui
parfois dans les discours des réseaux
sociaux dans ce à quoi nous habitions
est quelque chose qui peut menacer cette
liberté et dont il est mon devoir de le
rappeler voilà ce que je peux dire pour
cela mais je peux simplement dire que
demain nous aurons tous une pensée pour
les femmes et les hommes qui ont été
lâchement abattu parce qu'il dessinait
parce qu'ils les écrivais
parce qu'il corrigeait parce qu'ils
étaient là pour livrer pour aider parce
qu'ils étaient policiers c'est ça ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là
et donc au delà du procès qui donc sera
commencera demain et je n'ai pas à
m'exprimer sur ce point en tant que
président on aura une pensée pour toutes
celles et ceux qui sont tombés
oui je reviendrai en décembre oui parce
que sinon il y aura pas des chances
régulières donc en octobre deuxième
quinzaine et en décembre est-ce qu'à une
toute dernière question on fera en a
rentré un nouveau nom bruit à cinq
décennies d âme cd radio monte carlo
doualiya avant que vous venez en avez
août
votre entourage a laissé entendre que
vous allez demander ou aux représentants
des partis politiques de ces natale de
côté et l'émergence d'un nouveau
gouvernement et de nouveau deux régions
pour un laps de temps est ce qu'il vous
à ce qu'il vaut est ce qu'ils ont vous
écoutez à ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont vu
non mais c'est toujours la même question
et c'est intéressant d'ailleurs parce
que on a eu exactement le même débat
avec les forces politiques
d'abord moi j'ai rien à dire à qui que
ce soit j'ai juste dit aux intéressés si
ce sont les mêmes au même poste il ya
peu de chances que ça produit un
résultat différent
qu'est ce qui change la des réformes
clair un agenda à un mois trois mois et
un engagement de toutes les forces
politiques derrière cet agenda de
réformes au gouvernement au parlement
et la deuxième chose c'est de dire le
premier ministre désigné va constituer
un gouvernement de jean prob connaisseur
de leur secteur et de l'administration
est donc compétent et ce qui change
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas les
représentants chacun de la force
politique et là elles vont à doubler un
tout ok ensuite la feuille de route
je leur ai dit vous pouvez avoir
confiance il faut pas vous ayez votre
espion dans le gouvernement
parce qu'elle feuille de route c'est l'
autre manière impérative et les forces
politiques et ne se désengage pas
l'engagement qu'elles ont pris c'est de
dire on va s'engager pour dans les
prochains jours et au plus tard dans
quinze jours soutenir pour toutes à
l'exception d'une la formation de ce
gouvernement et ce gouvernement et on va
s'engager au parlons tout celle ci pour
que ces réformes à bout
et donc on n'est pas face à un
gouvernement de techniciens dont pour s
affranchir des forces politiques disant
ça n'est pas nous ce n'est pas d'accord
avec ces gens là tout est lié c'est ça
l'innovation de la démarche et son
caractère structure vous avez encore des
questions
non je n'ai pas évoqué avec le
patriarche on a évoqué une discussion
simplement sur ces propositions
oui mais nous ne l'avons pas évoqué pour
être honnête avec lui on a évoqué le
sujet neutralité il m'a dit sa vigilance
sur certaines volontés de réformes
institutionnelles et d' équilibre
confessionnel mais rien d'autre
allez-y la verge of un sans faute
monsieur le président quel est le
message que vous avez transmis à ce vol
à part le député brad exactement études
y étaient autour de la table avec tout
le monde donc ce que tous les autres ont
entendu un engagement sur le
gouvernement et les réformes et s'y est
engagé il a exprimé sa voix sur les
élections et c'est là où il ya eu un
désaccord entre plusieurs il n'était pas
le seul il fait partie de ceux qui
veulent pas d'élections anticipées est
pas changer la loi électorale
je suis pas sûr que ça soit une grande
surprise pour vous et que ce soit un
scoop et je lui ai dit pour moi ce qui
était une enquête indépendante parce
qu'on avait un problème de définition
sur le sujet et à la lumière de la
discussion je lui dis que très
clairement il y avait un problème
d'articulation entre une présence
militaire est une représentation
politique qu'elle ne faisait pas partie
du programme de réforme dans les trois
prochains mois mais que c'est un sujet
qu'on devrait engager dans cette
discussion il en est convenu peut pas de
plus exhaustif allez la toute dernière
je peux poser une question sur la
transparence s'il vous plaît du système
judiciaire libanais vous dit vous n'avez
pas la même définition d'une enquête
indépendante est ce que ce soit vous
pouvez dire que vous avez confiance
qu'il y aurait une enquête transparente
sachant que le liban est considéré comme
étant un des pays les plus corrompus que
jamais aucun ministre est allé en prison
et que vous avez demandé vous même une
réforme du secteur judiciaire est ce que
vous avez confiance dans laquelle de
fadi sawan ce sort alors d'abord la
réforme de l'enquète du système
judiciaire s'est amusé à lire dans la
déclaration
donc dans les trois mois deuxième sujet
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'éléments de
faits qui sont aujourd'hui établi par
les coopération technique internationale
donc il ya quand même des éléments
factuelle qui avance je peux dire que je
suis raisonnablement confiant sur le
fait que les faits ce qu'il s'est passé
les quantités en présence je crois que
tout le monde sera obligé de les
reconnaître
là on nous serons collectivement
vigilance et pour attribuer les
responsabilités voilà et c'est là où à
la lumière du passé votre scepticisme se
justifie voilà je vous propose de nous
arrêter là je remercie beaucoup à tous
voilà donc je vous avais compris là on
est vous d'octobre moi je reviens en
décembre et moi j'ai une pensée j'avais
parce que c'est ce que sa maman avait
fait ce matin que la petite camarade
tayama m'a remis mais j'ai une pensée
pour toutes les victimes du du 4 août
dernier et je crois que on leur doit
beaucoup de courage et donc j'ai
confiance en vous pour que vous soyez
engagé et qu'on soit tous engagés en
tout cas je vous ferai le maximum
croyez le minal beit-salam libéraux
[Applaudissements]
voilà
hélas